kerry vine ski merci d'être toujours
avec nous vous vouliez réagir à ce que
nous disait elena volochine qui se
trouve à belgorod exactement et qui est
capital parce que vous avez demandé à
l'ena le fait de savoir enfin comment
les russes jugé l'intervention actuelle
et léna fort judicieusement répondu que
les russes étaient sourds matraqués par
la propagande du du régime alors si
alors s'il ya un certain nombre de
choses diaby c'est quand même ça relève
de l'héroïsme valeurs sublimes parce que
c'est à ça qu'il faut penser en russie
vous pensez à ceux qui se battent vous
avez par exemple une télévision qui
s'appelle doj qui signifie la pluie qui
est une remarquable télévision
d'information ou de réinformation au
sens exact du terme et non pas la
désinformation de la dir poutine mais
tout ça est très ténue et puis toujours
sur le fil du rasoir vous voyez bien le
l'association mémorial qui a travaillé
pour la la mémoire exacte de ce qu'avait
été l'union soviétique et qui
aujourd'hui est menacé par le
gouvernement c'est quasiment fait
malheureusement deux d'être rayée du du
registre est interdite il ya pas un
journal novaïa gazeta
bien sûr y accéder oui mais vous savez
quand vous êtes dans la russie profonde
vous n'avez pas ces journaux là qui sont
essentiellement distribuées sur les
grandes métropoles russe et c'est tout
bête ce que je vais dire mais comment
voulez vous justement réfléchir quand
vous êtes dans une dictature comment
voulez vous ne pas être un mouton quand
vous êtes dans une disquette nature
parce que précisément les médias vous
empêche de réfléchir c'est tout bête ce
que je dis nous on a l'impression que
c'est naturel en occident parce qu'on
peut se fige se former une opinion là
quand vous avez internet qui est parfois
coupés et que vous n'avez que la
télévision d'état comme vous voulez par
exemple les documentaires d'alexa une
avanie le principal opposant à fuji est
en prison qui a fait ses vidéos sur la
corruption et les ballets et la force
d'une devrait devenir poutine ça a été
vue plusieurs alors juste cent mille
centaines de milliers de vues sur le
territoire russe n'a pas été aussi
facile que ça et parfois ça n'est pas vu
alors là aussi il faut prendre le
rapport de
force entre les deux quand on vous dit
par exemple quand la télévision va vous
dire la télévision d'état va vous dire
vous avez un documentaire de cet
horrible alexeï navalni qui est un
pourri et qui est un corrompu si vous
êtes un peu respectueux du pouvoir et
bien vous allez dire oui je le crois ça
veut dire tout simplement c'est d'une
banalité affligeante ce que je dis là
mais que pour pouvoir se former une
opinion il faut en avoir les moyens et
qu'une dictature c'est la preuve que
c'est bien une dictature qu'elle empêche
la formation de cette opinion alors
encore une fois un vous trouvez en
occident des gens qui disent en mai
finalement c'est le choix des peuples
vous n'aimez pas la démocratie essayé la
dictature et vous deviendrez des moutons
malgré vous même si vous êtes quelqu'un
d'intelligent et c'est ça la force de ce
qui est à dire aujourd'hui c'est par
rapport à la démocratie ça n'est pas un
vain mot ça n'est pas un concept
abstrait c'est par exemple dans ce cas
là le choix la possibilité d'avoir le
choix de ce qu'on entend est de savoir
ce qui se passe dans la ville d'après
c'est quand même pas demander le pérou
mais les dictateurs de type poutine et
sert les occidentaux parce que soyons
clairs l'extrême-droite occidentale
s'est déroulée objectif c'est des
godillots de vladimir poutine et nous en
avons malheureusement en france eh bien
ces gens-là méprise jusqu'à 7 à ce bon
sens humain qui consiste à dire pour
pouvoir faire mon opinion et jugés j'ai
besoin de matériaux et de matériel pour
le faire tout simplement pour revenir à
l'opération en cours cette invasion à
cette occupation ça va être une
opération sur le long terme d'après vous
et comment la population ukrainienne va
réagir alors tout dépend effectivement
de la réaction de la population est
chrétienne et des militaires ukrainiens
et des volontaires ukrainien puisque si
on en croit ce que disait ce matin
clovis casali il y à un certain nombre
de gens qui se portent volontaires même
s'ils ne sont plus forcément en âge de
combattre donc ça c'est la première des
choses
plus la russie essaiera de gérer
l'ukraine plus elle risquera de
s'enliser encore une fois ce que disait
marie mendras ce tout à l'heure c'est
quand même 600 mille kilomètres carrés
l'ukraine c'est plus grand que la france
ils continental bien donc pour gérer ça
il faut avoir l'habitude on a vu comment
l'armée russe avait géré d'autres sites
que ça soit en ossétie on apprécie ou
même dans le donbass même des surfaces
plus limité leur pose problème donc ça
c'est une première réponse est la
deuxième réponse c'est qu'elle sera
après ce qui est probablement la prise
de kiev qui seront les capacités de
répliques même si elles sont limitées de
l'armée ukrainienne
encore une fois on a souligné tout à
l'heure l'importance dans l'opinion
russe qui parfois doute parce que ce
qu'on a dit sur les médias dans la
russie profonde c'est une chose mais
malgré tout vous avez un assentiment
russes face à cette démarche cette
opération qui n'est pas formidable en
faveur de vladimir poutine donc encore
une fois si vous avez un certain nombre
de soldats russes qui rentrent soit dans
les boli bas comme on dit soit dans les
cercueils en zinc comme me disait elle à
l'écrivaine biélorusse ça je peux vous
dire que ç'a un impact très fort a à
maintes reprises on a pu constater que
les blés ce qui faisait vraiment baisser
la cote de popularité de vladimir
poutine s'était pas souvenez-vous le
koursk ce sous marin en 2000 2000 qui
avait explosé en mer de barents et les
familles ont déboulé à à mourmansk était
le port d'attache 2010 du sous marin
pour mes
agonise et d'injures le pouvoir était
celui de vladimir poutine tout neuf et
c'était pas du tout l'armée qu'on
remettait en cause c'était qu'avez-vous
fait avec nos fils ça peut être servir
de leçon merci beaucoup et qui arrive
une ce qui est d'avoir est avec nous
pour cette édition spéciale merci à vous
pour votre analyse et